alors je vous pose une question qui
parrot depuis très longtemps c'est ce
que l'entreprise peut être un lieu
lumineux alors je vais pas vous parler
de religion la question est la suivante
est ce que c'est un endroit un espace où
l'individu peut s'épanouir grandir
briller ou bien est-ce que c'est un
endroit plutôt sombre dans lequel le
côté obscur de la force va se manifester
et on peut se poser vraiment la question
par rapport à ce qui se passe dans
beaucoup d'entreprises
en fait cette ce point bascule entre
l'ombre et la lumière est une question
qui me passionne depuis de longues
années
ça pose la question du choix que nous
avons à faire tous à chaque instant
c'est qu'est ce qu'on regarde du monde
qu'est ce qu'on voit deux fois qu'est ce
qu'on voit de l'autre alors si je vous
raconte un peu mon histoire mais très
brièvement
j'étais plutôt moins un enfant timide
réservé souvent quand on est timide
réservée pas s'il y en a ici on est
plutôt observateurs et j'ai développé
l'art d'observer les autres et entre
autres de voir où est leur lumière
alors évidemment je regardais pas la
mienne je regardais bien celle des
autres je faisais la comparaison en me
disant à mon détriment que voilà j'étais
plein de défauts et plein de le plein de
travers et que les autres étaient bien
plus brillant que moi voilà donc c'est
cette question là ça a été une sorte de
quête et c'est devenu j'en ai fait mon
métier
donc ça fait à peu près 25 ans
maintenant que je m'occupe d'accompagner
les personnes à trouver leurs lumières
intérieures et a brillé à accompagner
les chefs d'entreprise leur équipe à
faire briller leur entreprise
on parle de performance je pas trop ce
mot là mais néanmoins c'est l'entreprise
bris l'entreprise brille il y aura de la
performance alors ce que j'observe c'est
que en fait dans l'entreprise il ya des
gens qui s'éclate qui s'épanouissent qui
sont qui sont réjouies on en a vu
quelques-uns
ce soir on voit aussi des gens qui
s'éteignent des gens qui souffrent des
gens qui se brûle les ailes le mot burn
out est un mot qui est apparue il ya
quelques années et il m'arrive
d'intervenir sur des cas de suicides sur
les lieux de travail donc je sais que
voilà ça préoccupe pas mal des
dirigeants et que ça affecte beaucoup
les collaborateurs alors moi j'ai envie
de vous poser la question suivante
est-ce que déjà vous considérez que vous
êtes un être lumineux dans sa cellule
bon est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez
une lumière en vous est ce que vous
savez d'entretenir la nourrir est ce que
vous savez voir la lumière chez les
autres je vous pose la question est donc
je vous propose un petit exercice ce qui
sera intéressant si on pourrait allumer
la lumière pour que vous puissiez vous
voir voilà l'idée c'est que vous
puissiez regarder votre voisin votre
voisine juste un instant observer les
visages voilà reprenez un instant
mettez-vous par deux ou par trois phases
voilà est juste un instant
alors vous invite à le faire en silence
voilà fêter incidence est justement
centre et vous pour observer par exemple
le regard les traits la couleur de la
peau observez vous un instant marché qui
est des gens pour les cas c'est très
difficile de faire ça mais en tout cas
je vous invite à le faire prenez la
photo
si vous voulez le faire bien faites le
en silence bien maintenant vous avez la
photo
fermez les yeux un instant et puis je
vous propose d'aller photographier votre
espace intérieur pour faire ça il ya
besoin de respirer
donc vous invite à prendre je vous
invite à prendre contact avec votre
souffle celui qui dit que vous êtes
vivant et plus vous contactez votre
respiration et que vous en avez la
conscience plus vous allez vous détendre
je vous invite à accompagner la
respiration de la détente est là
maintenant il ya une magie c'est laisser
votre main allait se porter à l'endroit
où est votre lumière intérieure
vous pouvez le faire comme ça avec votre
main peut-être vous allez la voir
ou peut-être vous allez la sentir ça
dépend si vous êtes visuels ou pas aller
au contact de cette lumière intérieure
et puis maintenant elle va imaginer tout
en restant dans la respiration et la
détente que vous avez un interrupteur
avec un variateur de lumière et on va
imaginer que vous tourniez doucement le
bouton jusqu'à ce que petit à petit la
lumière éclaire tout votre intérieur
laissez vous guider par votre corps il
cesse à lui
on pourrait si vous voulez vous amuser
imaginer une petite fée clochette qui va
elle est allumée une par une des
cellules de votre corps et un moment
donné vous allez pouvoir constater que
tout s'illumine bien si vous n'avez pas
réussi à faire l'exercice c'est pas
grave en tout cas vous pouvez ouvrir les
yeux et regardez maintenant le visage de
votre voisin de votre voisine
est ce que quelque chose a changé
on peut restreindre la lumière merci il
ya une phrase de goethe qui m'a nourri
pendant de longues années que je vais
vous citer ce poète allemand disait si
vous traitez un individu comme il est
alors il restera comme il est si vous le
traitez comme s'il était ce qu'il doit
être ou peut devenir alors il deviendra
ce qui doit être ou peut devenir alors
parlons de la lumière
justement il y avait un physicien
brillant nous avons entendu tout à
l'heure la lumière a des propriétés par
exemple la lumière véhicules de
l'information c'est comme ça qu'on peut
connaître l'histoire des étoiles par
exemple la lumière c'est de l'énergie
nous a montré que la lumière impact la
matière nous a parlé de la dualité de la
lumière cette capacité qu'elle a deux de
passer d'un état corpusculaire à un état
andullah thouars suivant qu'on observe
pour la mesure c'est une superbe
métaphore de comment fonctionne et la
question c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait de
l'information qu'on véhicule nous mêmes
ça veut dire que je peux chez l'autre
voire le meilleur comme le pire
je peut générer de la défiance où je
peux et générer de la confiance je peut
stimuler l'ouverture du coeur ou la
fermeture du coeur est ce que j'ai pu
maintes fois constaté c'est que le
résultat il est en face de nous en fait
nous créons ce que nous en voyons comme
informations sur notre environnement
alors ça veut dire que si je regarde
chez autres ce qu'il ya de plus brillant
et bien je vais l'accompagner à devenir
de plus en plus bruyants riant
si je me regarde comme un être de
lumière on va dire comme ça eh bien il
ya de fortes chances pour que je
continue à grandir j'ai adoré ce qui
était dit sur les enfants c'est
exactement ce qui se passe pour eux ce
sont des êtres lumineux alors vous me
dire tout ça c'est bien beau c'est c'est
quoi c'est de l'utopie c'est c'est du
bisounours on est dans les entreprises
c'est le cas de 40 et autres autres
places boursières
alors je vous propose de vous emmener
dans une entreprise que nous avons
accompagné je vais vous raconter
l'histoire brièvement de cette
entreprise donc il ménage et imaginez
une entreprise industrielle
ces produits sont de notoriété mondiale
le dirigeant qu'il a créé il ya 25 ans
n'a pas de successeur en tout cas
personne dans sa famille ne veut
reprendre cette entreprise et il est
obligé de la vendre à un groupe étranger
concurrents on nomme un directeur
général à monsieur brillant réellement
et un ans après qu'est ce qu'ils
constatent et bien il constate que son
co dire les manques de son codir
s'éteignent littéralement eux mêmes
parlent d'une coquille vide
en parlant du codir il constate qu'un
des membres du cos tir est en dépression
et constate que la défiance s'est
complètement installé entre l'équipe de
direction et les salariés il constate
choses très graves pour pour lui et pour
l'entreprise que les retards les
commandes prennent de retard de plus en
plus et que les clients s'inquiètent
donc il va faire appel à notre cabinet
est la question est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors pour mettre de la lumière je lui
ai dit voilà on va s'occuper de la
lumière
je vous donne quelques exemples très
concrets une façon de remettre de la
lumière un petit coup de fée clochette
là bas c'est de faire travailler les
membres du codir sur leurs rêves
voilà c'est plus c'était plus le rêve du
père fondateur c'était la question
c'était c'est quoi votre aide à vous
avez vous un grand rêve est donc ce rêve
construire une vision un spa bon
deuxième petit coup de lumière là dessus
pour eux c'est de mettre ce rêve en
commun pour construire une
un projet partagé un projet commun c'est
pas rien puisqu'il se parlaient pas
troisième petit coup de lumière on leur
propose de regarder les choses au
travers du prisme de l'autre et donc ils
s'aperçoivent que sur la même situation
ils ont des visions totalement
différente et au lieu de les mettre en
opposition et de se faire du conflit ils
se sont aperçus en fait que les idées
des uns des autres et est plutôt
intéressante et même brillante qu'il y
avait des ressources qu'ils avaient de
la richesse ensuite ce qui était
intéressant c'est que ce cheminement
petit à petit et comme si on a dû mettre
une lumière après l'autre les a amenés à
tomber les dark vador donc il y avait
plus de masques pour se cacher des gens
commençaient donc les membres de cette
équipe ont commencé à se parler vrai et
à dire ce qui se passait pour le et vous
pouvez vous doutez quoi et bien l'effet
papillon sais pas si vous allez donc
donc on a une équipe qui est capable on
a une équipe qui commence à vibrer à
vivre et à travailler ensemble les gens
se voient s'écoute se parlent et l'effet
papillon est très intéressant c'est que
ils ont rien eu à faire de plus que
d'appliquer comment ils communiquaient
entre eux avec comment il allait
communiquer avec l'encadrement
intermédiaire et rapidement entre
l'encadrement intermédiaire c'est bien
communiqué de la même façon avec les
ouvriers et les salariés
c'est en presse d'hier c'est magique
c'est pas magique
en gros il a fallu à peu près un an et
demi pour arriver à ce résultat qui a
été constatée de façon tangible
entre autres par des auditeurs qualité
qu'ils ont dit votre entreprise est
complètement changé on la reconnaît pas
alors qu'est-ce qui change réellement en
fait au départ il ya rien qui a changé
ce qui a changé c'est le regard que
chacun portait sur l'autre sur lui sur
son entreprise au lieu de focaliser sur
les problèmes focalise sur le projet au
lieu de se mettre sur un position
défensive basée sur la peur commence à
ouvrir le coeur et à se dire mais on
peut faire des choses ensemble on se
parle on s'écoute on coopère en
collaborent et donc ma conviction c'est
que cette vision de la lumière appliquer
à nous-mêmes
c'est une façon de pouvoir tisser une
toile de réalité totalement différente
voilà internet c'est une toile celle ci
c'en est une autre
il ya donc une façon de regarder
l'entreprise de façon différente total
peut être regardé en tout cas jusque là
alors je crois profondément que nous
sommes des êtres de lumières point vous
avez compris si j'ai pas cette
conviction je peux pas faire le métier
que je fais j'ai compris profondément
que je peut allumer ou éteindre la
lumière la mienne celle des autres et
j'ai une conviction et j'ai un rêve en
même temps c'est que ce temps que les
dirigeants et leurs équipes dirigeantes
ne s'impliqueront prat ne s'appliqueront
pas dans ce type de démarche
alors eh bien c'est il ya il ya quelque
chose qui qui est à changer à cet
endroit là et c'est ça c'est un de mes
rêves parce que quand qu'ils
s'impliquent et nous le voyons quand ils
s'impliquent
alors il ya des changements majeurs qui
se produisent entre autres ça ouvre la
voie à des modèles de gouvernance qui
sont totalement différent parce que ces
modèles là ils vont impliquer justement
le fait que
ya de l'intelligence du coeur dans le
système dans l'organisation alors on
parle on en a parlé tout à l'heure
d'entreprise libéré il ya des méthodes
on utilise un certain nombre le
changement émergents la sociocratie lol
acratie enfin tout ça ce sont des
techniques qui sont en train de se
développer dans le monde pour justement
mettre les individus au coeur des
décisions et non plus qu'on soit dans
une seul modèle unique descendant voilà
alors je vous pose la question suivante
qu'est-ce que vous allez choisir vous
l'ombre où la lumière
merci